tu préférerais être incarné en Michel
Drucker Jean-Pierre Foucault ou Patrick
Sabatier
bon Renault vu qu'on est à la télé je
vais te poser des questions à la con
mais vraiment des questions très con par
exemple tu préfères ton père ou ta mère
ça commence bien
j'aime les deux les deux mon préservé du
froid de la fin de l'ignorance
je préfère Hitler ou Staline Staline ah
bon si j'ai le choix mais entre la paix
et le choléra quand Hitler il paraît
qu'il aimait beaucoup les animaux tu
dois partir à deux pendant trois ans sur
un vaisseau spatial
choisir de partir avec Guy Bedos Anne
Sinclair ou Patrick Bruel combien
d'années pour trois ans
j'ai peur que ce soit une Sinclair pour
raison alimentaire
élémentaire tu aurais pu prendre Guy
Bedos pour faire du lest
si tu avais pas le choix je préfère
faire l'amour avec une fille très très
laide ou avec un mec très très beau si
j'avais en page
tu préférerais être réincarné en Michel
Drucker Jean-Pierre Foucault ou Patrick
Sabatier Michel Drucker sans hésitation
à qui trouves-tu le plus de
circonstances atténue entre un vieux qui
se tape des petites ou un jeune qui tape
sur les petites vieilles qui se tape des
petites de quel âge 12 ans un jeune qui
tape sur les tu rentres chez toi le soir
qui te ferait le plus peur dans noir
comme ça le Pen ou tapis
Le Pen
mais c'est toujours pareil entre la paix
et le choléra
tu as peur de le pen
y a-t-il une vie avant la mort
probablement mais ce qu'il y a une vie
avant sacrée soirée je suis pas sûr
mais pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu